vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
où vous voulez à mener celui que vous
avez déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast qui est en
croissance constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel qu'à cela ne tienne
dans le studio sf on loue le studio avec
tout le matériel donc tous les micros
tous les caméras si vous voulez faire
une version vidéo de votre podcast et ça
vient aussi avec notre technicien
extraordinaire nicholl nicholl qui va
vous guider dans votre projet c'est
probablement la personne au québec qui
écoutent le plus de balados indépendant
parce qu'il y ait derrière la console
surtout les balados qu'on enregistre au
studio sf donc il va se faire un plaisir
de vous accompagner dans ce processus là
si vous voulez plus d'information au
sujet de la location du studio écrivez
nous à sans filtre podcast à commercial
gmail.com
une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut avec nos invités date si tu
cherches quentin avec moi dôme plantes
cette semaine le sans fil très présenté
par notre page pitchouns ont fait à peu
près une fois par semaine 10 mois un
podcast excusé forme en paix tu risques
on est juste les deux sont ils
la dernière fois on se raconter
d'histoire de notre primaire la fois où
ce qui donne cet effet touché à la tête
par un oiseau entre autres accessoires
et on va en faire prochainement est ce
qu on veut répondre aux questions des
membres pétrone fait que si vous voulez
vous abonner c'est la meilleure façon de
nous encourager
le lien va être dans la description du
podcast trois pièces par mois vous avez
accès à tout soit fait qu'ali checker
là-dessus ce nom cette semaine d'hommes
y ait cette semaine on a reçu émile
blandeau auteur compositeur interprète
je ne crains qu'ils amoureux de la
culture d'avis angot passionnés vraiment
je pense que parce que passionné c'est
le mot qui décrit le mieux le puits
vraiment engagée aussi venu ici avec
toute son énergie concon laquelle on le
connaît depuis cet été ce pas une belle
discussion a parlé de culture parler des
de souverainisme ou kaki très
souverainiste par les diversités de
parler de laïcité
peter
qu'on entrevoit aussi la culture dans
les prochains mois en attendant dans ce
nouveau contexte nouveau monde dans
lequel on vit fait que c'était une super
belle discussion comme d'habitude par le
fonds de rencontrer emile bilhau our
guest abonnez vous à nos chaînes les
signaux des commentaires participer à
discussion on aime ça vous lire si vous
écoutez en ce moment en audio les sinois
writing sur les applications audio les
signaux un commentaire là ça fait son
bout de chemin
parlez-en à vos amis puis bonne
continuité de ce confinement qui semble
achevée on va voir on se croise les
doigts fait que bon papier est yes man i
corte
[Musique]
r ouais merci d'être là mais ça fait
plaisir les gars merci d'invitation
toujours un bonheur de voir déjà en ce
moment de ses sofas malin exact fait ou
l'autre moi j'étais à rosemont petite
patrie puis j'ai déménagé en avant c'est
que j'ai réussi à je me suis débrouillé
veut veut pas sans savoir a dit cette
mutuelle je pense que c'est pour le
mieux je m'explique
chez mes parents mon frère
ça aurait été différent je pense que le
vix a tout coller ensemble je me trouve
chanceux dans le déroulement des
événements d'avoir mon nouveau chez moi
pour affronter son va tout seul qui
s'imposerait ça me permet de faire de la
musique de penser à mes affaires de
faire des projets je trouve ça cool
d'être dans mon univers de former mon
univers les journées se ressemblent à
quoi m'attendre
ben moi j'ai un nouveau projet c'est
s'aider instagram live en fait je reçois
des amis hauteur pour booster interplay
un grand ferry tout les samedis soirs
cette lancée le 1er existait un autre 20
minutes avec le deuxième la caisse en
face à faire ce travail de recherche
comme on peut comprendre les étapes de
leur carrière et d'habilité puis ça ne
veut pas ça ça crée un peu du travail
nuits sonores faire que j'aime bien ce
que c'est vraiment quelque chose que je
me suis donné comme défi dans ma vie à
faire connaître la musique au québec
parce que bien qu'elle a et plusieurs
plateformes je trouve ça important de
montrer j'avais des petits bouts j'ai vu
de dessus de 25 ans d'un truc qui te
reçus un par dessus et coach jérôme
c'était malade le mot puis jérôme et on
s'est parlé 20 mai deux temps selon ton
souvent parce qu'il est à québec mais on
a parlé lui étudiants en enseignement
qui on a parlé de son rapport avec la
jeunesse dans ses musées on ne parlait
aussi d'indépendance
on a parlé de comment qu'on pouvait
venir en aide aux salles de spectacles
lecteur dans les grands centres chose
primordiale au québec c'était justement
sinon moi j'ai reçu un gars bush a sorti
son dernier album récemment sarah dufour
qui est une fille du coin ou ph vu le
jour c'est à dire à l'aîné à dolbeau
mistassini
après ça j'ai reçu pierre hervé goulet
un goût de la bonne
je sus caroline savoir pilou advienne
cassidy plus la semaine prochaine puis
aymeric saint cyr de mort du seigneur
c'est vraiment un projet qui me tient à
coeur
il le fait que ce soit à chaque samedi
ben ça me donne le repos c'est pas trop
demander
en fait le fait de garder un jour comme
seul et j'imagine que c'est un genre de
formation continue pour toi exact je ne
sais pas qu'est ce qu'est ce que la dîme
réserve mais j'aime beaucoup faire de la
télé j'aime beaucoup faire de la radio
fait que de m'ouvrir cette porte là j'ai
créé mon propre style et à une
éventuelle carrière de l'époque
chroniqueur culturel parce que je pense
que si je fais de la musique c'est
vraiment à cause de mon amour ma culture
le scac est plus que plus que ton plus
qu'une prédisposition à la musique c'est
vraiment l'amour pour la culture
québécoise
ouais c'est ça je sais pas d'où ça vient
je pense qu en fait je pense que la
culture veut comme elle est très liée à
notre société les artistes qui dénonce
des artistes qui surf sur leurs portes
samedi beaucoup sur sur qui nous sommes
pays où est conservé au puits d'où est
ce qu on vient c'est que je pense que ce
rapport la hêtraie je suis si de ce
rapport écoutez aussi j'ai peut-être pas
de cas ce que tu as fait avec adamo le
10 mai lexmark synode a pas de parler
qui était rentré dans une boutique un
peu de création de vos projets elle
situe encore de la formation sur pause
d'été là dedans que quand sa déco
semaine c'est est une bonne question
d'âme ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
avant de confinement que la coved arrive
à nos portes
moi j'étais déjà en écriture de mon
troisième album c'est un troisième album
qui avant la quarantaine qui tout ça
parlait déjà de vulnérabilité et
d'isolement fait là je vais en même
temps je suis content parce que je sais
qu'il est
me rejoindre le monde parce que ça va
être proche d'eux m'a même pas ça me
fait chier parce que j'aurais aimé ça
arrive et puissent comprendre le monde
lorsqu'on connaît ma bosse et la copie
dans ce jeu mais j'arrivais avec une
vibe un peu plus un peu plus à 6 puis je
trouve que mais en même temps peut-être
ce qui est difficile c'est de penser que
dans deux ans toutes les artistes vont
sortir des albums plus que témoins n'ont
pas la même couleur que tout le monde
alors que c'était possible je dois pas
le cas ce dimanche au match je parle de
dizaines mal vulnérabilité 18 tirs je
parle aussi des personnes âgées qui
conte mais dans une semaine il ya un âge
écrit une chanson sur un personnage
horacio arruda
[Rires]
d ailleurs les gars là je trouve une
bière puis j'en profite du fait de la
pub pour peter riboud une bière la
gaspésie mon émission les s'appelle une
guerre irbil si c'est ma grand-mère
efforts à chaque fois les coûts zeita
plaisir m'appelle tout beau trop de bien
mais là c'est que marina regarde pas sa
baie james et j'aime son ton attitude
ans voire tous qui québécois ça mais ça
me rend fier on dirait attend lui-même
chez darty ou puis ça transparaît aussi
à travers ta musique
c'est cet amour là qu'est ce qu'elles
sont mais ton les aime en grandissant
quelles ont été tes t/t vecteur de deux
passions pour le québec le niveau de la
culture le bal - premièrement j'ai
vraiment une philosophie qui se transmet
dans ma vision du sport du travail
si cette idée là de jouer pour la bonne
équipe
c'est vraiment important pour moi parce
que je t'aurais travaillant je suis
assidus je suis un
j'arrive à l'homme je pense que si je
fait tout ça depuis que je travaille
aussi fort c'est pour le bien à béton de
monts
c'est pour le bien de ma famille de mes
amis et je pense que ça ça veut dire
joindre plus la vision g de travailler
tous ensemble au québec pour le québec
mon nationalisme est vraiment basée
là-dessus c'est quand je regardais des
plus petites nations à travers le monde
qui eux ont leur drapeau dans le
dictionnaire qui eux peuvent faire des
compétitions sportives dans des
plateformes mondiale comme les
olympiques ou la coupe du monde mais par
exemple a annoncé qu'au québec on est à
moi je me range tout en un peu les
doigts je dis pourquoi oedipe au museau
aplati fait que moss et c'est aussi tout
les artistes qui m'ont parlé de ceux qui
parlaient monmarché blair le joual que
j'ai vraiment pu comprendre que je t'ai
qu'issus de cette gang-là c'est que
jamais ton camp des 10 danses à tourner
dans ses notes de l'es10 j'en ai plein
mon cas ce n'est pas encore l'heure dose
et des moins l'acheter comme des
français sa pour ses coins j'en ai plein
mon cas c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
me rejoint la bruère inside puis ça
c'est vraiment une philosophie sur
laquelle je surfe le pour encore
longtemps
puis commence que dans comment est ce
que tu es ce que tu l'appliquent
consciemment dans ton art à toi mais je
me suis aussi en toi tu cette espèce
d'influencé le doute souvient est ce que
c'est ce que si tu y penses tu l'aplec
juste parce que c'est un toit based ans
que je fais un peu des deux à ses yeux
c'est sûr que dans tout ce que je dis
tout ce que je fais il ya un an vie
politique de vouloir brasser la soupe
lui de ramener les souverainistes de
toutes les deux de tout les horizons
mais en même temps je pense que mes
chansons à mes vidéos tripes mes
références ça votre soi il ya pas
vraiment c'est quand j'ai fait un un
vidéoclip a qu un castor puis qui
parlaient en attendant qu'une demo
dernier vidéoclip tu parlais de la ville
de montréal qui qui interdisait de faire
des feux dans les maisons foyers
directement
on sait se remettre la qualité une
stabilité la turquie refuse et qui a
interdit les feux de foyer fait que
c'est comme un approche très
terre-à-terre de comme moi je parle d'un
moment ça se passe dans ma ville il ya
encore un castor qui est quand même un
emblème de notre territoire
oui en entrevue je laisse beaucoup de
france pareil parce que j'ai des du
politique gd but de rassembler mais
quand c'est mon or c'est tellement en
moins ça que j'ai même plus besoin
d'homme fort c'est une fable ce qu'elles
font c'est vraiment un nationalisme qui
est poète il peut diviser par toute
l'équipe et polarisant la série
nationaliste déjà et on est tout de même
gagné la roulotte c'est un peu comme air
comme rarement fiori est elle tenable et
oui une fille chérie c'est un exemple
d'homme parce que lui c'est origines
italiennes et quand il est arrivé qu'à y
arrivent à terme on n'a pas tout nous
dire oui la jeta un italien qui réside à
montréal puis j'avais des rêves le
québec m'a aidé à les acheter
allez les achever à les entretenir ses
rêves le jeu trouve second qui font
vraiment je pense au québec astier de
redorer l'image de la terre d'accueil
malheureusement à eau au québec je pense
qu'on a perdu plusieurs plumes vie faut
pas pointer du doigt personne faut dire
qu'il ya une montée de la droite à
travers le monde c'est au brésil aux
états unis pour ne nommer que ceux-là
fait que moi je suis juste là si j'écris
une chanson qui s'appelle feu du mercury
c'est mon deuxième album klô pelgag mext
à la bonne personne pour nous parler des
différences qui d'acceptation pense que
le premier couplet et beaucoup axé sur
accepter son corps accepte et qui nous
sommes dans une différence il deuxième
couplet plus dans l'idée d'accepter les
autres cultures les autres couleurs
faites moi j'ai écrit cette chanson là
parce que je regardais mon québec parce
que je regardais la loi 21 avant que
tout le monde trouve sur l'acac parce
qu'ils font du bon travail formidable
pour justement montre un bon leadership
merci c'est vrai que la loi 21
sas a lancé un drôle de message sur le
nationalisme québécois parce que la
pièce se définit comme étant un
nationalistes souverainistes qui veut
vraiment aller chercher toutes ses
pouvoirs politiques dans la
confédération qui vraiment respecter la
vision québécois ce qui est quand même
noble et il faut l'avouer mais par
contre on s'est un peu pris les pattes
avec ce si vous voulez auprès en parler
plus longuement à vous décider
mais tout à fait on peut en marquer là
dessus mais j'ai l'impression que cette
loi le été perçue beau de la haine
raciste par par beaucoup de gens à
l'extérieur du québec même si les
intentions j'ai l'impression était pas
celle là moi je suis d'accord avec toi
je suis d'accord avec toi il faut savoir
première manquée mois ci le coup d'en
parler c'est justement à cause de l'eau
puis après je pourrais te parler de ma
vision québécoise de cette loi
premièrement il faut comprendre que
quand à matonge talent et au nunavut
faire le show était muet et puis là on
était reçue par des canadiens
l'un disait on s'est bien amusé c'est
vous avez de la difficulté avec les gens
qui viennent d'autres cultures
moi je trouve ça difficile de subir ce
regard alors que je sais qu'elle canada
la difficulté d'accueillir les
francophones en lofts et victoire en
leurs institutions
ok sa première affaire nous ce que je me
dis c'est que il faut il faut vraiment
qu'on aille cette discussion là en tb
quoi sans se faire traiter de raciste de
l'autre bord
parce que là c'est sûr que le le pôle it
mais le dialogue juste avec quelque
chose de polémique parce que on va taxer
un peu de côté le fond du débat pour
dire on n'est pas des racistes vous êtes
des racistes le débat va tomber dans
l'huisne qui fuit dans le goudron dans
l'image
la fameuse expression intéressant d'un
point de vue québécois c'est que si on
se donne la capacité d'en parler à ma
tondeuse
mir pays puissant mais ton était seule
au québec indépendant
on se donne la possibilité d'en faire un
débat national chose qui n'est pas
arrivé parce que françois legault le mit
le droit du bâillon kanté majorité de
petits sachets j'ai trouvé ça difficile
parce que qu'est ce qu'elle dit cette
loi là elle dit que toutes les femmes
voilées par exemple si on prend les
humains ne peuvent pas enseigner ils
peuvent pas enseigner qu'est ce qu'elle
soit 10,5 maintenant tes profs le au
sujet mais tu vois une jeune femme
bouali qui tuent des rentes ont coupé
qui dit moi mon rêve c'est d'être
enseignante
ben si ton devoir en tant qu'enseignant
de dire il va falloir que je choisisse
entre eux en torrent
pita personnalité de la personne que tu
es ici il faut que tu fasses un il va
falloir que ça c'est un sacrifice envers
ta philosophie religieux je sais sur
quel style
est ce que ça dit pas des grains donc de
venir travailler ici les grands partis
de nous mais vous devez faire partie de
nous
en ayant 10 ans soit moins intéressant
parce qu'on sait le théâtre juge être
policier c'est payant dit moi quand je
vois des gens qui pensent dans les
institutions en santé je suis pas
l'équipe type jamais un juge vaut mettre
de l'avant sa spiritualité pour donner
une sanction à quelqu'un parce que si ça
si ça arrivait mais cette personne ne
l'aurait renvoyé que je trouve que la
loi 21 et les problématiques et je
trouve ce disque de raciste à part les
autres canadiens alors que c'est un
débat qu'on devrait avoir entre
québécois parce que c'est quelque chose
d'important
puis on est une minorité dans le canada
fait que c'est difficile bonjour de
dîner avec les autres minorités
tabarnak je prends une bonne assise en
ligue 1 je vais vous lancez une question
par rapport justement à la loi 21 paires
la laïcité de l'état
moi étant un jeu peut-être j'appellerai
passe aux activistes athée mais en étant
un athée qui qui juge qu' un monde sans
religion serait probablement bénéfique
dans ma conception du truc
j'ai l'impression que là
la laïcité de l'état c'est quelque chose
qui à mon avis fait du sens d'un point
de vue philosophique de se dire on va à
mettre en place des institutions qui on
veut pas les laisser à être affectée par
aucun symbole religieux par aucune
religion tu es fait que le concept de la
laïcité de l'état m'apparaît comme un
concept qui fait beaucoup de sens
oui ligue ensuite une fois qui une fois
qu'ils aient vraiment avoir été pris
hors contexte par quelqu'un qui entend
se sent tout là ça a vraiment pouvoir
voir plus loin que juste le sait
exactement ce que tu dis de de prendre
un cas précis peut dire eto'o alors que
tu en joues que tu change de job j'ai
l'impression que si comme le la
dichotomie entre la entre la réception
pile là qu'est ce qu'on veut vraiment
faire puis moi je trouve côté je trouve
que deux en tant qu'etat de prendre le
de prendre le contrôle de dire on enlève
la religion de l'équation
je trouve que c'est quand même loi qui
comme une émission progressif quand même
je suis comme musique ou la raison pour
laquelle c'est tellement un sujet
important qui bouillent en les québécois
mais certainement envers une population
un peu plus vieillissante
c'est que 1 des grandes réussites de
notre état sainté la révolution
tranquille quand on a réussi à mettre la
religion catholique à l'extérieur de
notre système d'éducation de santé
d'enseignement je fais c'est en nous on
est fier de ça j'ai l'impression que
dans la loi 21 heures les gens l'ont vu
ils y ont retrouvé la fierté d'un des
bons coups qu'on a fait en 1960
mais là c'est ça il faut vraiment qu'on
arrive à définir ensemble c'est quoi
l'image qu'on veut donner à notre nation
une nation qui a toujours été reconnu
comme étant une terre d'accueil pour les
communautés francophones à travers le
monde
dis moi je trouve que du cil comme tu le
dit elle sur le terrain puis dire un
jeune professionnel qui étudier là
dedans depuis quatre cinq ans lui dire
désolé mais au québec croit pas à avoir
le travail pour lequel tu as travaillé
si fort pour lequel tu rêve depuis
longtemps parce que nous autres
on est mal à l'aise moi personnellement
en tant que jeune québécois tu sais tu
vas en avoir de plus en plus des
couleurs au québec
chose difficile de commencer ma vie de
jeune citoyen avec cette contrainte est
absolument raison mails que ce malaise
le vient d'un traumatisme de fromage de
la génération de nos parents qui ont
vécu leur jeunesse en étant dans des
dans un système où la religion contrôle
est pratiquement toutes les sphères de
l'éducation et ceux qui ont leur jeter
pis si c'est une bonne chose mais c'est
sûr je pense que justement cette peur le
cette crainte le demeure oui mais le
monde a changé c'est le bon de changer
beaucoup pitt et c'est pas un danger
pour les professeurs qui enseignent aux
primaires avec un voile cpie à vos pour
ces post qui vous réécrire sait si les
fondements d'un système d'éducation
reste laïque si pas parce que dans sa
confession personnel d'enseignante et
d'une telle ou telle religion qui ont
changé quelque chose
si elle applique jeudi relais
l'enseignement selon lequel au québec
ont prescrit le tiendrait sur tes pieds
je peux je peux être un blanc puis avec
un signe religieux puis j'ai enseigné le
créationnisme à mes élèves c'est exact
c'est pas mon symboles religieux qui
définit comme en paca précise aussi de
juger la compétence de chacun au sein du
lobby poste lorsque la lame vraiment
selon le seul ont su comment ses
compétences son contenu puisse on se
rend compte que certains convictions
personnelles wallon compte de programmes
ou de quoi que ce soit qu'on qu'on veut
qu'on veut partager qu'on veut enseigner
à la prochaine génération l'oeil un
problème mais sinon à nos pauvres
je trouve cela intéressant tout ce que
vous dites que je pense qu'il ya un
point qui revient dans ce qu'ont dit les
trois c'est comment dire le concept de
la peur de l'eau le concept de la peur
de l'eau c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'intéressant je pense que c'est la
bonne en fait de la création de cette
loi là et moi parce que ce que je dis
pour contrer cette peur la croix de
mieux que quand tu es jeune d'avoir
quelqu'un devant emploi de différents
kits enceintes est gentil avec toi qui
as mettons cette enseigne le français
claude la perception des gens qui
viennent d'ailleurs change le pour toi
c'est un c'est un acolyte c'est
quelqu'un qui veut du bien
moi quand je checke la fugière qu à
québec on sent que c'est parce que son
nom mais lui l'a si jeune il y avait eu
une prof ou un prof issu d'une minorité
qui l'aurait vu comme un allié je pense
que sa conception de sapeurs aurait été
différent moi je trouve ça aberrant
qu'on dit ouah mais si si si s'ils sont
trop présents auprès de nos jeunes nos
jeunes vont virer extrémistes voyons
donc la gang c'est le contraire quand tu
fais une association d'idées de
quelqu'un de différent tu la sauce ya
quelque chose de positif
je pense qu'une société en sort tout
tout tout a grandi à laval rive sud doit
donc sagement que j'imagine qu'au
secondaire 2000 perche on vient de
québec
les études primaires et secondaires
étaient majoritairement à touré
de blanc le t2 québécoise qu'on appelle
de souche je pense que j'ai jamais eu un
professeur au delà des élèves le je
pense que j'ai jamais eu un professeur
qui était pas nous l'en québécois dans
les ports de la plupart des la diversité
nous dans nos classes c'était
il y en avait très peur pis c'était
beaucoup plus des enfants adoptés que
des enfants étaient vraiment quelqu'un
qui arrive au québec et que c'est une
nouvelle culture le typha qui est
d'accord on en aura on a vraiment eu le
le contact de toute la culture l'homme
mais j'imagine que toi ou secondaire où
ça doit être très omniprésent au moment
d'amorcer une des grandes chances que
j'ai eu dans ma vie je me trouve
chanceux parce que ça l'à beaucoup
affecté mon travail la perception
nationale à montréal le beauport c'est
là que les opportunités de travail sont
les plus fréquentes
puis le récemment la commission marie
victorin ça c'est la commission scolaire
de longueuil qui chapeaute 11 secondes
derrière mon primaire puis si je ne
m'abuse le sujet ne suis pas convaincu
belle à l'eau fait une manifestation
pour la diversité fait j'étais avec des
jeunes de 12 ans et moins
kla on marchait dans les rues de
longueuil lyon on triait la la diversité
l'amour de la diversité qui est
intéressant dans cette commission
scolaire c'est que cinq ans 53% à dire
plus que la majorité sont issus de
l'immigration que ce soit en mer
génération deuxième ou troisième
génération fait que quand j'ai vu tout
les gens avec leurs pancartes
c'est à cet âge là c'est pas des
affaires éditorial à la martin all je me
rappelle les pancartes c'était comme
c'est un paradoxe il y avait juste écrit
je vous aime pour c'est une belle
journée c'est des jeunes qui ont tous à
8 10 m qui coûte quand je regarde ça
puis que j'essaie de les projeter dans
un futur où ils vont se faire dire quoi
pas le droit d'être une police soit pas
loin d'être enseignants n'ont pas le
droit d'être juges - ça me connaît sa
terre mais aussi et c'est pour ça que
pour moi ce discours est important et je
ne dis pas que les gens qui sont pour la
loi maintient ses désastres câble je dis
que c'est un débat qu'on doit avoir plus
longtemps c'est un débat qu'on doit se
faire sans le regard du canadien d'un du
canada parce que le canada prendre
quelque chose de différent
or un style tout ça plus intéressant
ghadamès non merci
c'est parfait c'est rare qu'on a ce
genre de conversation là en plus on a
reçu le groupe des semaines alors
skating fournit la députée oui j'avais
vu c'est mon ancien député moi j'ai eu
la chance de disputer plusieurs fois
parce que tu zappes la même vision
justement d'un nouveau solde du
souverainisme plus inclusif qui
s'approche choix d'être juge de sauver
quelqu'un qui veut la souveraineté de
nos jours tout repos mais pourra voir
l'espèce de 2,9 talent giddins du québec
de retard le sens le québec change de
québec au contenu change et il faut
l'accepter il faut construire à partir
de petites bien dit dom puis si on peut
faire un ensemble lien avec le deuxième
référendum je trouve que au delà de la
défaite référendaire ce que fait plus
mal et je crois que c'est le discours de
parisot la dernière phrase dernière
phrase qui dit ce qu'est ce que sur
l'argent et des votes ethniques
malheureusement je pense qu'on voit un
peu et l'héritage de ce même mois il
faut savoir que jacques parizeau
j'aurais été 100 milles à l'heure avec
lui pour faire un pays avec ce cerveau
là c'est grandhomme économique
ce grand rassembleur mais partons il
faut l'avouer ça ça a été une gaffe ça a
été quelque chose auquel on y est on a
hérité aujourd'hui absolument puis au
delà de la gaffe la perception je crois
que ça l'a fait que beaucoup de
partisans qui sont radicalisés en
prenant ce comme étant une des raisons
principales
en prenant comme du cash puis
possiblement que c'était des vrais était
à ce moment là mais probable que j'ai
l'impression qu'en ce moment il ya
vraiment deux catégories de
souverainistes puis celle qu'on parle en
ce moment ticket vers un québec ouvert
mais quand qu'on sort un petit peu de
notre chambre d'écho on réalise qu'ils
ont un québec beaucoup plus radicalisés
qui est qui et qui a des propos de
droite très extrême puis ça je trouve
que ça fait sept mois ça me fait peur un
petit peu à l'intérieur même de ce
mouvement là d'avoir une aussi grandi
côte amitié je pense que c'est ça
s'appelle radio-québec maintenant
un gain qui fait une émission sur
youtube mais s'est vue par des centaines
de milliers de personnes pillent les
pistes assez radicale quand même comme
propos le typique est ce si j'ai pas
trop sur quel pied danser parlera pas du
tout parce qu'au final cela la
souveraineté talent but mais le moyen
d'y arriver est en très différentes
écoute je pense qu'il faut faire la
souveraineté pour les bonnes raisons ce
qui est important quand tu te retrouves
à des groupes comme celui là ou à la
meute s'est pas nécessairement d'acier
de les convaincre mais je pense que
quand quand tu t'adresses à mettons à un
auditoire succès face à quelqu'un qui
d'être actifs qu'ils pensent vraiment
des idées de 2,2 blanche tu depuis de
tradition au prix de 10 c'est important
c'est de convaincre les gens alentour de
toi tu peux peut-être même ses enfants
où elle veut manger
moi j'écris de la musique avec des
messages cachés avec c'est quand même
accessible à tous pour que si jamais un
père pour tout pour une raison ou une
autre
au delà de la haine envers une minorité
bien que si les comptes maktoum dans
radio qui se disent sans fin la con ou
une porte parce que trouve
malheureusement trop souvent on devient
héritiers des valeurs de nos parents je
pense que c'est de voir avec ce qu'on
fait nos plateformes d'aller chercher
ces gens là c'est important de leur
montrer d'autres visions qui de leur
montrer au québec le seul ennemi pense
pas vraiment à temps par les ports puis
j'ai vraiment l'impression que c'est
comme le moteur de peur de l'autre mais
aussi par peur du changement justement
quand tu as l'impression que
l'immigration ça vole ça vaut effectué
en charge marc dad
ou tu te situes dans sois tu hésites pas
de faire chipoter on attention ils vont
voler nos jobs y vont souvent ceux qui
vont voler nos femmes non mais d'une
part justement des comme mon confort ma
manière de vivre et émana city ben moi
je pense qu'il faut ramener ça à
l'éducation ces gens prennent un pack
jérôme samedi passé c'est le nerf de la
guerre c'est de montrer à travers le
monde de montrer les flux migratoires et
de montrer que personne personne n'a
envie de s'en aller de son pays parce
que - reçu le premier là on accorde un
amour particulier à nos terres à notre
famille à notre culture
et si ces gens là ils partent c'est
souvent parce qu'ils n'ont pas le choix
puis moi je trouve que c'est notre
devoir de les accueillir de leur montrer
la beauté de notre nation de vraiment
mettre l'accent là dessus comme ça ben
il ya vraiment des liens discret qu'on
n'est pas vraiment deux ont des passes 2
contres on est ensemble
si je pense que l'éducation dans les
cours d'histoire dans les cours de
philosophie doit utiliser de plus en
plus le thème de l'acceptation ses
soldats la guerre est une question en
question un peu philosophique mais tant
pis qu'ils apprennent aux gorges et
attend qu'est ce qui définit un
québécois au tabac là bas normand fortin
les deux albums des bilodeau
non m je pense que s qui est sur la
piste et je le vois pas ce que je me
promène à travers le québec avec mes
chansons
on est des gens qui aiment faire la fête
ça c'est sûr on est des gens jovial des
gens généreux des gens très originaux à
ce que veut pas il faut être original
pour persister avec notre langue
depuis si longtemps dans une amérique du
nord bond et d'anglais donc je trouve ça
un peu à l'image de dédé fortin et on
est des gens humbles
c'est souvent un peu tabou
on est des gens humbles originaux parce
que on est des artistes sont reconnues 4
le monde pour un travail qui se fait la
plupart du temps en joual notre humour
notre sens de notre change d'humour pu
notre sens de la création qui on est des
gens qui aiment faire la fête
moi quand je m'envoie à mes temps je
sais pas - à rouen et qui te chante j'en
ai plein mon cas c'est tout le temps
j'en ai plein mon cas ça on a chanté de
quelque chose s pétrole albertain pleut
tout le monde sont comme ouais mais
peut-être dans l'est des gens c'est
qu'ils se touchent en regardant des
photos de la reine
mais un jour ils sont avec moi si et
tripes pour un show chaud que ça la
musique ça nous rapproche lui mots aussi
je trouve que ça ça défini mais ma
question je te colle tout ce que tu dis
ma question c'est plutôt qu'est-ce qui
fait pas ce qu'on pourrait dire mettons
tout le monde qui habitent sur le
territoire du québec est un québécois
serait légitime mais je pense quand même
que peu importe que tu sois blanc où tu
peux importe quoi je pense que vous qui
est comme un désir de de vivre ensemble
with péala
qu'est ce que le cheval de bord ou de
l'autre le tir parce qu'on pense que je
veux dire parce que tu aimais tant que
pourrait ne pas parler français
tout juste arrivé ici mais je pense que
si elles le désirent de participer à la
collectivité b je fait de lui un
québécois
ben c'est intéressant ce que tu dis par
rapport à la population anglophone au
québec parce que moi je veux dire qu'un
profond malaise quand je regarde
amateurs de poésie musicale
quand je regarde les banques comme
arcade fire ou à ceux qui connaissent
beaucoup de succès malheureusement j'ai
l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas su se
sentir aidés par les institutions
musicales au québec autant on vit
beaucoup avec la la surprotection de
notre langue qui aujourd'hui quand je
regarde le succès de ces deux bandes ne
par exemple milk and see j'ai comme
l'impression que ils y ont de la
difficulté de se dire québécois parce
qu'une zone on finance beaucoup les
projets trancault phone le calque toutes
les textes en français toutes les
bâtisses et ça fait en sorte que quand
même et on ouvre ce grammy musique un
jeu pourtant gagné le grammy de l'album
de l'année avec 6 à 5,6 me fait
carrément s'affiche comme a même si
j'aurais pris j'aurais aimé ça qu'on
leur donne plus de poids à cette idée de
tomber sans financement pour les projets
francophone je trouve qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on nous plus la porte à
cette population
je pense à leonard cohen qui jouent au
mix amat qui est un grand québécois un
grand montréal est malheureusement les
gens de mon âge ne connaissent pas tous
c'est important de comprendre l'histoire
puis l'apport anglophone au québec pour
ça que moi dans les 12 mai des petits
mots en anglais mais c'est sûr que si on
est loin des j'ai l'impression que c'est
vraiment un excellent point un truc que
tu marques avec leonard cohen puis j'ai
l'impression que faut faire la
distinction entre protéger la langue
française et en fermer la porte
à l'influencé extérieure au city puis je
pense qu'en ce moment il ya comme une
espèce de bons métissage qui est en
train de se farder hier il ya pas plus
tard qu'hier en fait patrick watson à
tout le monde en parle guy le dire je
trouve que c'est un bon exemple de
chrome os qui n'ont patrick watson qu'un
qui parle en entrevue au québec qui
parle en français chantant en anglais
puis on l'invite sur des plateaux comme
ça puis je pense que peut-être que c'est
en train de se faire plus
oui charlotte garde m6 très bon exemple
qui pourra venir la partie quoique
symbolique est en cours
parenthèse jeta les voir le show kart
watson s'était karkwa la bande annonce
si la bande à patrick c'était malade
liant les deux voies sur les succès des
autres qui eux non c'est ça ton raison
je pense que un métissage du fait que
c'est pas mieux
parce que là le québec on veut pas être
la gagne si à se surprotéger on veut
faire partie du monde
je pense que c'est vraiment sur le
projet que je que j'essaie de défendre
le prendre sa place et qu'on serait
gbagbo dit prendre sa place en fermant
et douanes vient un temps où vas tu vive
le panis bleus mais je sais c'est bon ça
me fait penser inquiète faire je me
rappelle qu'il y avait quelques avait
gagné le grammy je prends un peu plus
comme un casse appel à la régie
régionale avait à la fin un petit
message en francs français voit les gens
dans les écuries montréal merci québec
en france et c'est trop cool on est
telle qu'ils quittaient le fun parce que
je crois même pas qui elle est juste
passé francophone est haïtienne de
quotas qui soutiennent
oui exactement le même vraiment métissée
examinons tout le tarn indique yves mot
réalité c'est puissant il faut continuer
d'encourager son il faut que les gens se
sentent montréal est important parce que
c'est une belle ville qui est
c'est je veux dire aller tellement
beaucoup commando serait valorisée par
par la musique le monde exactement défi
le dynamisme culturel type moi j'essaie
de mettre sur pied un projet pour se
donner des fonds ou petites salles comme
le lion d'or qui débute
le ministère parce que c'est vraiment
ces petites salles là qui font de
montréal ce qu'il est c'est-à-dire une
ville où tu pas les moins chaud alors
que tu lui as place que tu es avec 10 kg
mais en ce moment c'est ça le sont dans
le trouble
exactement il ya eu un article qui est
sorti sur le lion d'or mois le lion d'or
c'est une place spéciale dans mon coeur
c'est là qu'ils se passent les
francouvertes de ce que j'ai fait de
bons lancements aussi de mon premier
album puis j'étais allé voir des shows
incroyables
ja c'est avec l'équipe que j'ai tous les
moyens du sport décret déjà des fonds
tout en montrant l'exemple
moi j'aimerais beaucoup donné une bonne
somme d'argent parce que ces places là
ont mis sur pied les coeur de pirate et
berné c'est là qu'on a eu la chance de
suspecter aïeul avant de mieux faire
nous tournons album mais les
francouvertes choc de ces croisés lève
le pan de retard oui avec et aria est
toujours première toutes ces stars us et
que tu es toujours mais elle est jeune
mais huawei d'ici et la suzuki ont été
annulés dans la foulée c'est triste mais
tous et ouais je trouve être qui tutoie
est un jeu joue à l'unité pas paroles
des paroles buveurs de bière avec les
biens professionnels et c'est vraiment
que je savais faire
malheureusement les porte parole s'est
il se montrait plus par terre moi j'ai
été très inspiré de l'île dominique la
chanson et on l'a su redonner on la
surnommait line de tequila haut hier
mais elle a reculé à chaque cinq demi
finales a prôné une terre battue dans le
bar le macintosh blaha mettait de
l'alcool fort
à chaque demi-finale les gens ne gardent
tous membres qu'il a affirmé le
barracuda jouait de la guitare jouer au
golf dit moi quand j'ai vu cela quand
j'ai vu quelqu'un connaître autant de
succès est autant connu acres aussi
généreux et qui disait aussi chasseur je
pense que je me reconnais en vous quand
je commençais que j'écrivais les tours
grises de green bay qui cessa l'apport
je pense qu'un porte parole doit mener
c'est de leur dire que ça s'peut et puis
quand on parle de sexe zakarian pitot et
la grenade
je n'ai pas l'impression d'être en plein
ébat tallinder sa note est vraiment le
fun pour les artistes justement d'avoir
cédé des porte étendards qui ont réussi
pique son ami milieu puis qui parle avec
eux autres tu peux tout le temps à
prendre déjà cameco ph s'est agrandie
par exemple il ya des invités qui
viennent nous parler du métier
que ce soit en édition des trucs c'est
unique détruites vocale des trucs de
droits d'auteur via chi x je m'en
rappelle jamais dit certain qu'ils
commençaient leur conférence en disant
dont l'oeil en au 24 mai j'aimerais vous
dire que statistiquement il ya des
chances qu'on a un qui perce mais il y
en aura pas un cri statistiquement que
tu es comme tu commences s'étant pas le
goût de l'écouter tout ça c'est
important des gens disent oui ça se peut
oui j'ai 23 j'ai deux albums qui est je
garde mon avis puis et je fais du monde
pour qu'ils méritent
je trouve que ça c'est plus important
que je devrais chanter comme ça c'est
important
si la nation de percer le succès jeudi
après il ya plein de musiciens artistes
qui sont pas notre critique chocs sont
pas télévision mais qui font leurs
patientes qui arrive à en vivre quand
même le nom exactement même si l'on est
chez elle puis c'est les honnêtes écrit
des textes de deux excellents moteur qui
donne des textes à d'autres artistes qui
ont très bien leur vie pour eux ça leur
plaît c'est juste auteur compositeur
d'une toune pas besoin d'être sur le
stage devant 10000 personnes seulement
de son échelle de succès habituel
le succès est vraiment relatifs le
admettons - qu'est-ce que je considère
comme du succès est-ce que je considère
que de faire
la musique qui te permet de payer
mettons un trois et demi
d'abord puis tes déplacements
est-ce que c'est du succès moi je trouve
que c'est du sang crise le tir moi aussi
j'étais obligé d'avoir une maison d'un
point 5 millions de faire de faire des
shows dans le centre bell le titre exact
c'est c'est quétaine à qui ce que je
veux dire non mais david le seul but
mais ton n'est pas le seul but mettait
un début je dis dans la vie c'est d'être
heureux c'est ça l'important
je dis si tout était heureux sans fard
un salaire incroyable où sans être
connue de tous riches et célèbres pour
toi c'était des pions de bonheur ben oui
je sais ce que tu aimes tu fais de la
musique parce que tu fais moi perso je
dirais qu'il est stable scud ont mis sur
un piédestal c'est certain type de
succès mais josé ch'ti malheureux ou
cités est un truc tu que tu sois connu
ou riches toutefois tous malheureux il
faut être au centre de cure tout ce qui
définit tout cas moi le bonheur c'est
d'être à bonne place outre haïti six
mois ça continue dans ta ligne et nantes
a pu ces deux questions le plus agréable
dans mon métier c'est de rencontrer des
gens rencontrés autant public d'autres
artistes je pense que on a la preuve
aujourd'hui puis pour vrai ça ça me
nourrit infiniment de peser le coût de
ce qui se crée de ce qui se fait de ce
que le monde pense qu'ils pourraient moi
je regarde pourtant des finances georges
papaconstantinou remet mans puis je
conviens que ça reste quand même encore
une couple d'années parce que je me dis
que si j'avais roulé dans les semences
dans mes revenus
mais ma perception de comment et
pourquoi écrire des taux de change
alors là aujourd'hui il fait des
chansons parce que je veux vous dire ça
j'écris des chansons parce que jégou
d'exploiter cette musicalité là j'écris
pas des tonnes pour payer sa sauce au
diane's a estimé
non c'est moi c'est le succès pour moi
c'est d'avoir la chance de faire des
spectacles de rencontrer des gens qui ça
peut être ça peut sembler common facile
peu rêveur
mais c'est essentiel pour moi de jouer
avec d'autres musiciens de prendre une
bière avec d'autres auteurs compositeurs
de penser à des vidéoclips avec d'autres
créateurs quelque chose de complètement
différent de moi et c'est pour ça sans
parler des revenus et de la chance que
j'ai de penser à la radio c'est pour ça
que je pense que je suis heureux parce
que je fais ce que j'aime
je suis convaincu que les gens vont
trouver la force les gens qui sont aussi
persuadés que moi de faire ce métier là
contre vents et marées c'est baumann
c'est beau merci si je te pose cette
question là en fait je te poser ces
questions-là puis-je être laissé
répondre
est-ce que
avec moi c'est souvent une question de
le pose sur médias ce qu'est ce que je
suis est différent avec un fini de
ressources béton c'est tellement le
c'est une question aux bonbons mon beau
pays
enfin il va prendre ils ont dit non mais
c'est sûr qu'ils m'aiment et béton dans
ton art mais aussi à l'échelle de ta vie
parce que moi je me pose cette question
là je me dis souvent pas grand chose
pas grand chose c'est sur moi je parlais
comme tout y est je pense que j'ai
réussi à trouver une touriste dans ta
question je pense que je redonnerai ozon
exacte et temps prendrait plus de temps
voire un peu plus pour toi tu le sens
exact même si en ce moment là je trouve
que cette crise là a vraiment ouvert une
bonne porte
sauf les travailleurs essentiel qui leur
manque de revenus lors manque de
ressources
puis moins pauvres est soudainement un
prix à l'automne je te colle discret
tout cela dans leur poche même qui bien
emballé avec un beau ruban parce que ces
gens là aujourd'hui ces gens là se sont
pas des professionnels ce sont des gens
courageux courageux joe don c'est à dire
à toutes les heures à tv que c'est
important d'être confiné que c'est une
maladie dangereuse zéro n'existant vieux
aux autres ils sont ils sont quatre
catapulté dans les hôpitaux dans les
résidences avec des salaires ridicules
qui je sais que c'est être proposé dans
une économie des torts il n'y a pas de
pauvres comme de dérivés pour que les
toques france du cash etc ça mais c'est
important de mieux définir
suite à cette crise là l'apport de ces
gens à l'eau sans penser à une approche
économique est ce que tu es optimistes
par rapport au retour de cette crise là
on en parlait l'autre jour depuis - puis
on se disait on peut même possiblement
qu'ils ont on était semi optimiste
devant l'idée que l'être humain est ce
qu'ils épient souvent c'est l'argent qui
doivent tout puis que possiblement que
que qu'on allait revenir
pas grand choses allaient changer
surtout tu tu le vois comment je pense
que c'est notre job c'est vraiment notre
job parce que
tout dossier qui est en quittant un mode
alarme je pense notamment au dos et
écologique
je pense vraiment qu'un coup à jouer là
je pense aussi qu'ils je pense que veut
pas il va falloir commencer à penser à à
une bosse d'un nouveau système
économique parce que ça peut être bon
sens que des mères monoparentales avec
un revenu minimum se retrouve à vivre
dans ce système là
et puis ces gens là ont pas le temps de
faire les manifs guide est en tabarnak
c'est il faut il faut qu'ils aillent à
joe cocker nourrir leurs enfants
moi je pense que il ya vraiment un
problème de ce côté là au point de vue
écologique au point de vue même si le
partage des ressources partage dans
l'argent je pense que je pense que moi
je suis pas la personne pour la fin ils
veulent chanter parce que je le sens
parce que j'ai des amis qui m'en parle
souvent mais définitivement qu'il ya des
gens qui sont beaucoup d avantages et à
cause de notre système on peut ne pas
s'avancer là dedans mais mais je pense
que ça passe par quoi est ce que tu
penses que ça passe par un système de
jeu surimposition ddd dirige des
industries qui sont qui sont déficients
5 % d'entre elles commencent à se
manifeste
ben alors en ce moment on peut le voir
le fédéral donner de l'aide financière
aux entreprises qui étaient dans les
paradis fiscaux ont toutes commencé par
là c'est des gens qui refusent de payer
leurs impôts leurs taxes qui organise
des mado et pour quoi redonner à un
territoire que leur donner les
opportunités de s'enrichir à une
population qui la partie prenante de
leur économie
dollars chiffres des taux de financement
je trouve ça ridicule c'est je pense
qu'on devrait commencer par la bride aux
vraiment commencé dans son mépris doit
vraiment fait une gaffe il ya manque de
leadership encore une fois canada nous a
laissé tomber
il donne d'ici pas à des grosses
compagnies qui font qu'ils sont dans les
paradis fiscaux alors qu'il ya près de
belles pme qui fonds d'aidé qui font des
produits qui respectent l'environnement
qui engagent des indes ici question
appelle l'argent pour avoir la tête hors
de l'eau c'est une des plus grandes tant
qu'à moi le christ est passé dans les
médias je trouve c'est fait pratiquement
ont vu et au su de tous le tipi souvent
ces mêmes
les galaxies et fils des filiales des
compagnies à numéro
c'est ce à quoi ils pensent que jean
rions pas et ils sont en droit de
pardonner à la société qui les ont qui
les ont aidés à avoir du succès
économiquement c'est absurde c'est comme
si moi je disais à mes frappes
je ferai pas de show aussi gelé pocho
gratuit c'est ridicule
les gens ont besoin les gens qui ont des
industries ont besoin de la population
pour acheter leurs produits
ces ions besoin de faire partie de cette
société là quand je vois des
ultra-riches arrêter de financer les
hôpitaux les écoles parce que c'est ça
des infos plus des taxes
j'ai juste le goût comme j'ai déjà sort
est encore jeune de prendre des armes
merci c'est une manière de mettre des
bombes le nom d'îles aller ça fait 10
mètres c'est une manière de parler parce
qu'à un moment donné si la personne qui
fait rien si les partis politiques
minoritaires qui ont ces idées là se
font en format à l'assemblée un moment
donné les gens qui subissent les
injustices il va falloir qu'ils fassent
humaniste une manif avec les poings
fermés
je crois qu'on promouvoir la violence
mais jeudi l'urgence est là
cette prise a fait ressortir tout ce qui
avait de pabos dans notre société qui va
falloir mettre les points s'il y en
sortant du sud te fait peur je pense
qu'il ya plein justement de choses qu'on
s'est fait remettre dans le nez
justement sa nouvelle affaire dans les
injustices on y voit plus bien des jt
c'est certain que les salariés
bénéficiaires après cette crise là même
le baril tu n'auras pas aussi aux
janvier sans la population tient avant
on pensait dans l'univers populaire dans
l'image marx était déjà en battant déjà
en repos givet la belle vie c'est alors
que nous on travaille des gros chiffres
annoncés gens le vivent de l'isolément
livre y vivent à un danger de mourir en
ce moment certes knoxy avait danger
moore il sans dignité et puis il ça il
faut vraiment au québec particulièrement
qu'on redéfinisse le lien avec nos aînés
nos sages sont bas aussi la société
juste et beck à grands coups de taxes
d'impôts dit dès le début et puis de
savoir que ces gens là demeurent en ce
moment dans leurs puces dans leur merde
ça me fait extrêmement de peine qui il
faut former 10 10 et on les met en
résidence
mais à ce qu'il n'y a pas moyen de
repenser le système d'avoir un aîné chez
nous de mettre nos aînés en contact avec
la jeunesse que ce soit si ça s'est vu
récemment le design et qui gardait des
enfants il faut il faudra définir un peu
le lien qu'on a et le rapport qu'on a
avec vous saviez le ca des vies
difficiles je pense pie xi quinquis et
personnes l'hôtel rachid où les gens
n'ont annoncé avoir la charge arts
maison une personne de notre dame c'est
pratiquement une job je dis pas que
c'est impossible mais c'est extrêmement
difficile non qualifiés aussi pau pour
ce qu'elle fit jacques sur des demandes
d'examens tous bords se remet à avoir
ces personnes à la maison et 40 notre
système fonctionne pas mais c'est quoi
le meilleur c'est tellement difficile
jeudi car quand on n'y a pas pas encore
tout à fait depuis ce matin ben oui
après ce quelqu'un qui a un temps que
c'est bien ce qu'ils risquent comment tu
dois t'arrêter de travail devient
exactement la mission difficile mais est
clairement que à ce moment les
conditions jeudi et s'est soldée
les gens sont entassés ils sont
plusieurs par charles x des conditions
de vie avez vous quitté la vidéo de
catherine dorion là je vais pas faire je
vais pas faire de propagande politique
ou si je ne pouvais pas montrer pour qui
je vote
mais catherine de rien en fait un vidéo
un incroyable elle une lettre d'une
femme qui s'est porté volontaire à les
aider dans les résidences qui a su
retrouver à gérer une vingtaine de
personnes aînées sans formation pialat
voulais juste aider à faire des tâches
annexes qui assure trouve à ceux qui
s'occupent de 20 à 10 elle est débordée
le stress est immense puis le
traumatisme de voir des gens mourir des
gens en détresse
il faut vraiment que le québec
redéfinition à la fin de la crise le
faut juste qu'on mette des drops et
consommons clape en bas il faut alors
qu'on s'assoit que marguerite blais
c'est là depuis longtemps
la ministre des aînés un autre plus
longtemps il va falloir y poser des
questions il va falloir aussi quand on
invite mais des représentants syndicaux
à venir parler de vendredi mais n'est ce
pas ça fasse c'est quelque chose de
dramatique je le répète c'est des gens
qui toute leur vie comme vous et moi on
travaille et on payé des impôts ou des
taxes en fait de société une société
juste
puis qui se retrouve complètement
démunis s'en servait sans ressources
sans unité vraiment une urgence
nationale
je pense que tout le monde d'accord avec
ce et qui est un problème ça n'a pas de
bon sens je pense que l'afrique est mal
fait bon ça sent pas bon ce serait
presque inhumaine dire que c'est pas
grave je donne tout le monde trouve ça
grave parce que l'autre on vote autres
ceneri dieu je veux dire c'est comme ne
veut pas il ya quelque chose aussi de
très égocentrique dossier là je pense
mais je t'ai après ça c'est à chaque
citoyen si tout le monde
toulon tout ça pas bon sens maintenant
chez russie qu'on paie trop d'impôts
qu'on fait trop de taxes et c'est avec
un terrain après ce faux aussi accepté
que tous eu un coût qui doit être
content de le payer parce que tu paies
aussi pour le toit de deux tons pâles
moi je te regarde train de gauche la fin
qu avez vous un port une fête comme à la
date du québec je l'aimais énormément de
ces camps quand on regarde leur dette
on peut comprendre aussi toutes les
acquis qu'on a qu'elle reste de
l'amérique comme parti aux états unis
par exemple le fait de pouvoir à
l'hôpital tandis le sait quelque chose
on peut être fier la société qu'on a
bâtie si je pense qu'en ce moment aussi
co réalise la chance qu'on a d'être
québécois d'être canadien ne veut dire
avec toutes les mesures toutes lettres
qu'on a je dis moi un moment tu penses
tu à sion de stress financier parce
qu'ils aident les deux audi fait
d'erreur je suis aux états unis pis
mettons j'attrapais et qu'on ait virus
ou une autre maladie
peut-être deux fois avant d'aller me
faire traiter parce que ça me coûterait
vidéo date est là c'était soit d'agde
gouvernementales comme on en a ici pacte
est on est on est on est chanceux les
discussions on a les discussions qu'on a
sur notre société sur notre identité sur
notre culture
parce qu'on peut se permettre de prendre
le temps de discuter avec une bière avec
notre faim je pense que oui on est
chanceux d'être privilégiés mais faut
aussi continuer de parler de cette
société-là on serait fou de justice est
fermée à rennes
non il faut il faut les avoir ces
discussions l'entrée lorsque sinon on
fait du surplace qui les inégalités
restent les mêmes c'est c'est leur en
turc au kit aller à tout le monde en
parle qui disait que après cette crise
le lui qui allait voir
c'est son rapport d'impôt égale à être
content de le payer ma lettre
tout le monde n'était parfait meilleur
exemple une belle solidarité sort on
peut peut-être lettre c'est terminé et a
tranquillement sur le côté positif de la
crise vous voulez bien premièrement je
trouve que l'apport des gens des enfants
en est un qui est quand même assez
exceptionnel
je sais que le ça va bien aller c'est
vraiment une idée d'un dessin avec un
arc en ciel puis ça s'est vraiment venu
de là la petite jeunesse québécoise qui
réussit veut pas à me mettre un sourire
et plastiques à qui on va surmonter ça
aussi pour eux parce que pour le début
de la crise les enfants c'est à des
vacances
mais un certain moment donné c'est en
août et ami tu t'ennuies temps aux profs
s'ennuie d'apprendre que je trouve que
la jeunesse a été vraiment exemplaire a
vraiment été solidaire sans même le
savoir
ouais tout à fait tout à fait je vais
avoir en fait je pense que tout le monde
a été sur le dirt et dans l'histoire le
puits ses preuves dans le positif que je
vois de tout seul et épique au début
possiblement que ma pensée changer un
petit peu mais ma première réaction
quand quand le gouvernement a pris des
décisions assez drastiques rapidement
puis que tout le monde a embarqué dans
ce puits que personne ne semblait
s'opposer aux mesures ma première
réaction a été de dire waouh prévoir
tout le monde embarque dans ce bateau là
sans poser trop de questions parce que
c'est c'est la direction qu'on va a
laitiers puis ça me rend très optimiste
par rapport à par exemple la question du
changement climatique de dire qu'un
convoi être qu'en faire face un mec
c'est une urgence déjà mais quand qu'on
va être rendu au pied du mur
qu'est ce qu'on va faire ça me rend
pousse ça m'intimide pas réparation
maintenant est ce que ma vision
optimiste du projet de société à changer
un petit peu quand qu on voit que
maintenant les penchants économique est
en train de tirer son sabot de son bout
de la corde pitt ou peut-être un petit
peu mais somme toute je trouve que ça a
été un espèce de tout le monde ensemble
on met la main à la pâte on met l'épaule
à la roue peut vraiment oui je t'écoute
des expositions sur les changements
climatiques php logic tel un podcast
avec une scientifique et que c'est sa
spécialité est aussi prof en sciences
politiques parce que sur ma climatique
et politiques citerai interreligieux
puis à 10 est la différence entre la
crise va t'on ducourneau virus pillay
les crises climatiques si la vitesse à
laquelle ça se déploie virus et sa
dépouille
excessivement rapide mars est arrivé
vite et on prend des mesures rapidement
tandis que jamais climatique ça se
déploie en cela c'est très intéressant
c'est vrai c'est vraiment dur on a pu
sauver ne veut pas par la véracité de
cette candide là on s'est dit ok on
travaille ensemble pour à midi alors que
les catastrophes naturelles arrive de
manière lente à s'agresser mais aussi de
plus en plus est concentré dans une
année mais vraiment l'augmentation est
l'engrenage
mais tant que le virus ça a commencé
quand des sangles mettons en chine en
novembre peut-être de cette volonté ne
fait pas longtemps qu'on parlait
quelques mots maintenant la vie
radicalement différentes les quelques
mois plus tard un nouveau monde dans
lequel on vit
et je maquille massy qui ça fait des
décennies voire des siècles que
l'engrenage et commencer puis spéciales
et cela disait en ce moment mettons dans
les changements climatiques où on a
amené dans l'évolution de la crise c'est
l'équivalent de navires us à la deuxième
semaine de mars
ces cas que c'est un peu de fans depuis
que l'on signe a capoté et qu'ils
aillent que le mélo à ce moment à
l'aller on est rendu au mode 11 mai
au québec on a on ne peut pas encore
atteint le pic on pas qu on commence la
crise climatique seppi on faisait ça a
été excessivement longs facile ça va
durer longtemps fait excessivement long
avant qu'on puisse en sortir qu il nous
reste juste à l'agression il réussit à
poura ghz 6 à 10 en ce moment là à cause
la macro économie russe les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sont drastiquement
coupé en ce moment pour l'environnement
c'est vraiment une bonne nouvelle
politique mauvaise nouvelle pour
l'environnement c'est une bonne nouvelle
l'a laissé ces changements lui ces
coupures de démission ne sont pas
certains de bosses on veut parce qu elle
en ce moment les lisent moins en paie le
prix t mais si on arrive à trouver une
manière de
des gardes et 7 6 sachez qu'il a
vraiment à l'autre en apparence on tue
le bien dit le tc télétravail ça va
prendre une grosse coche dans les
prochains dans les prochaines années
c'est sûr volée et ouvre y penser deux
fois avant de prendre l'avion pour eux
rien tient meeting mettons combien
business meetings il ya des avions les
qui font new york los angeles pour 50
pièces parce qu'il ya des signaux qui se
rendent à une place pour avant un
meeting en personne ça veut s'en aller
c'est moi j'ai l'impression économie
locale aussi le casting et énergie avez
vous vu le pétrole drop et aymen trop
c'est quand même pas mal parce que là on
est en train de redéfinir le plan
national canadien de caen
ok les compagnies pétrolières acheteurs
ils doivent acheter leur vol ils sont en
train de donner du cachet à des adultes
a marre de ce monde pour qu'ils achètent
leur pétrole personnes en utilisent pour
se déplacer je me trouve ça cool parce
que sa loupe peut-être une porte a
justement hockey le pétrole a fait son
temps maintenant peut-être aller
chercher une ressource naturelle moins
coûteuse moins polluantes
avec tout ça c'est des dossiers qu'on va
devoir quand je vous disais affaires
vont aller dans la rue pour pour
témoigner notre envie de se sortir le
sceptre de ce service citées le pétrole
pour le canada depuis longtemps commente
entrevoit le retour du milieu artistique
écoutez c'est une estive en question moi
j'ai une maison disent qu'ils
travaillent chaque là parce que je
prends du bac tout est en tournée en ce
moment ah oui même plus ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'industrie de la musique qui
se nomme est pas à ses premières poc
on est heureux on a aussi un public
comme je le disais quand je devais
définir ce qu'était un québécois un
public très attendrissant envers ces
artistes envers l'ex pris artistique que
ce soit l'humour la musique la danse le
théâtre qu elle est venue avec moi je
pense qu'on va être capable de se
remettre mais pour l'instant je pourrais
pas vous dire ça va être quoi le plan
ce que je sais c'est qu'on peut acheter
des albums ce que chez c'est qu'on peut
acheter des films on peut encourager les
artistes qu'on aime on parle acheter des
oeuvres visuelles aussi donc il faut que
les gens pensent à ça puis moi je
voterais pour leur dire longtemps tout
les samedis à 22 janvier aux
francouvertes mais est ce qu'ils vont
tous finir le concours d'une certaine
madame année on sait on sait pas c'est
tout est le plus de peine d'homme parce
que chaque année aussi à bien bosser ce
que je trouve ce test parce que tu mets
ton moi moi je travaille beaucoup car
yann c pillet joue avec un lie avec help
si ses entrailles en studio 6 mois de
gestation
c'était vraiment faim mais justement
c'était comme le moment métiers
souffrent et l'accusé parce qu'il ya du
monde tellement plus à prendre qu'une
zone métier on faisait crisser leurs
sorties mais à faire là faisait ses
lancements les français cela était
premier troc aux gros buzz le dôme c est
la nouvelle cuvée qui arrive à chacun et
cette cuvée l'oeuvre sur arte à un frein
est interrompue dollar momentum je pense
à mon âge je reviens à mon chum gab
bouchard vient de sortir un album
incroyable si tu fais un show sa tournée
ça a été un chaud c'est la soirée le
gouvernement a annoncé les mesures de
250 personnes et moins vu que c'est une
salle de 250 personnes les moyens on
peut faire un show c'est drôle parce que
mon film est sorti avec une équipe c
tres pareil en afrique exactes n'ont pas
su s'adapter très vite à rien at on
déclaré
c'est clair que j'ai la confirmation que
les frais le couvert sont annulés la
plaie qui leur est trop ce matin une
question pour toi une question que
que j'avais posé à catherine brunet
dernièrement sur le podcast seulement en
tant que nationaliste hier comme toi
catherine fourni excuses
non non catherine brunet a donné aucun
nom je salue la sphère 2000 avec juillet
exact ça faisait longtemps j'avais pas
lu cette écoute écoute poppy la question
que je posais c'était admettons qu'il ya
un extraterrestre qui arrivent ici puis
qu'il veut il veut aussi de comprendre
toutes les toutes les différentes
personnes qui habitent de sa planète
toutes les différents pays toutes les
différentes nations puis qui demande qui
arrivent au québec puis qui veut voir
trois affaires je suis moralement je
monte ma grand mère ma grand mère du
côté de mon père
l'acsa torres va pogner diminue il va se
retrouver avec une gente dame crie t on
c'est bien justement qui ont un
vocabulaire saguenay délicieux riche
petit je pense que avril c'est à vous
donner une petite bière de la région
puis je pense qu'il faut sentir toute la
chaleur
après ça j'ai fait rencontrer leurs voix
s'il a la mecque le sucre machine la
plus calibrée de l'autre nation via
précieux en écoute ci pour l
extraterrestre
je la mènerai voire un sur deux dans le
l'outil mois ecofan il faut il faut la
ville cette culture là et qu'on peut la
décrire autant qu'on veut mais il faut
aller à en région il faut à l'armorial
flers québec il faut aller voir c'est
quoi pour rencontrer les gens de toutes
les cultures de toutes les couleurs je
pense que l'extraterrestre un gros c'est
que cette question là le avait déjà été
posée puis ont même des jeux et la sonde
voyageurs ayant envoyé sur dans l'espace
le maintenant il rendu plus loin quel
système solaire du combo
dans le vide puis il commet un disque
d'or là dessus comme plein
d'informations sur les humains qui aussi
tu peux faire jouer le disque qui est de
la musique là dessus puis je pense pas
qu'il n'était pas étonné qu'ils
envahissent lyon me premièrement comme
des dessins des d'un jean d'un homme et
une femme tous nus utica l'école pour
qu'ils voient comme une menace à bakwa
avec un peu des indications genre
interstellaire de qom où se trouve la
terre d'enfance ont la tête ailleurs
d'animaux télé sont des nations unies
ont mis la musique va le chercher c'est
que camille puis en islandais de langue
des landes saint lô me jean sébastien
bach
ah ben oui on y est
[Musique]
ils y ont mis de la musique de toutes
sortes de teddy mexique sénégal une
semaine dernière album des deux frères
n'ont pas oublié cet ennemi d'état a
beau père rien ils ont mis plus tôt la
fin de la wii comme tout genre espèce de
condat si on était sûr taille
c'est un bel exercice de juste ramener
parti c'est quoi un humain sur terre
type de jeu jusqu'à mener ça l'essentiel
de juste vivre sous ce thème
s'intéressant ouais parce que par c'est
sûr que je vais pas d'un point
l'extérieur de quelqu'un qui aucune
crise id et puis c'est ce que j'écoute
est il une marche qui était sur le
podcast de joe gilgun derrière maintien
il parlait beaucoup d'intelligence
artificielle et de guillaume
possiblement un espèce de d'implantation
dans ton cerveau qui permettra deux
autres de communiquer sans parler avec
un langage extrêmement efficacité parce
que quand qu'on essaie de parler on se
perd dans les dédales d'aider des
langues puis le mettons l'information
que j'ai que je veux vous transmettre
foca pas par ma voix faut que vous
l'archevêché il faut que vous
interprétiez fait qu'il ya beaucoup de
chances que les messages soient pas
exactement celui que je veux avec les
parlait beaucoup de films d'animation
fap de communiquer sans par les tiques
vous expertise mais mon idée à votre
idée sans saveur père en soit cet
épisode qui a appelé son flow et puis
joe rogan il fait un bon travail quand
monde de la mer disant amen mais je
comprends ses hôtes
c'est cool mais me semble que quelque
chose de riche à entendre quelqu'un
s'exprimer comme du monde avec un
langage c c de l'énergie aie
quoi que ce soit de l'artiste la fca
relève tout la couleur toute la salle
aristide way ou de ne rien comprendre
il ya quelque chose aussi
ouais d'entendre des sons que tu connais
pas de voir déjà communiqué avec un
langage que tu comprends pas et quelque
chose là dedans aussi
ces derniers à ce qu'on disait justement
on tout début d'entrevue le sort est le
fait d'accueillir le monde veut faire
partie notre société c'est d'avoir des
couleurs c'est d'abord veut pas aussi
une certaine éthique
pensez-y la musique à mettons les
haïtiens qui est ici même s'ils font des
griots c'est d'en avoir accès à cette
richesse-là culturelles culinaires
musicales artistiques de toutes les
points de vue et des professionnels
aussi des cerveaux et qui c'est qui ce
qu'ils font c'est un certain succès dans
des domaines d'avoir accès à ce wave
muscat vraiment dubois radio à jogger
d'embrasser des différences évidentes
gracile et moment justement où on doit
aussi de se comprendre qu'ils essaient
d'avancer l'argument del bosque sait si
on peut se permettre d'être dit que
trente secondes c'est de dire que tu es
mettons en ce moment la symbiose entre
l'homme et la machine l'espèce de
transition vers être un cyborg le sait
est déjà à temps mais dans son ski on a
déjà des téléphones de tam et aux autres
qui est au téléphone avec pop art and
écrire une chanson là c'est justement
violent le refrain c'est comme comment
les gens faisaient avant pour les ponts
le monde devait vraiment être
intelligent si c'est vraiment cette idée
là que quand je pose une question là me
plaît c'est comme la pose bien des
questions
messi avait pas gogol est il à tour est
pas drôle mon cerveau est gros comme une
carotte est ce que mon cerveau est gros
comme une carotte studio ou juste un
homme de mon époque c'est vraiment cette
relation-là de l'aecid quasiment motion
plus jeunes étoiles à l'école est-il gay
mais de devenir connaisseur de d'un
concept ou dans le domaine
ce que je me dis je du montcel problème
ne sais pas si c'est tu l'a convaincu
que moi que ça dessus quand même là la
beauté où la poésie ou la relance malgré
qu'on soit connecté
je sais pas si on allait procéder après
vous en fait c'est sûr qu'il faut que ce
soit c'est c'est sûr qu'une
centralisation des opinions
puis que pour vraiment j'ai l'impression
que maintenant c'est plus rare mais ton
quelqu'un qui va réussir à ça prend un
bison pour amener une nouvelle idée
mettons le lundi où un nouveau sol puis
je dis pas ce mot péjoratif le t1
bizarre à mon avis tout ça ça prend un
blizzard pour amener quelque chose de
nouveau que j'ai l'impression maintenant
c'est plus difficile d'avoir des
bizarres exact j'ai l'impression qu'un
des générations qui s'en viennent à être
plus difficile d'avoir un bizarre parce
que il voit une espèce de globalisation
de il va en avoir encore il va toujours
avoir des bourleux qui vont faire laura
fryer mais j'ai l'impression qu'il va
peut-être avons un petit peu moins de
dix ans que le monde a besoin de besoin
tellement même tellement mais si cela
revient peut-être un concept du regard
de l'autre
on a par des différends ne perdent pas
été mais tout avec les réseaux sociaux
entre autres ne veut pas on est en train
de vivre la l'époque des réseaux sociaux
à 100 milles à l'heure avec la crise
mais les réseaux sociaux continuent de
bars et notre gorge sous qu'ils sont
beaux qu'ils sont moins bons qu'ils sont
drôles qu'ils sont moins
malheureusement je trouve que ça ça va
faire en sorte que moins de gens à
sortir du lot mais c'est important qu'on
encourage ces gens là à être ce qu'ils
sont
moi je le fais en valeur la chanson qui
s'appelle je suis jaloux c'est important
amène parce que changer le monde tout à
fait et merci beaucoup mais les gosses
étaient tellement intéressant donc c'est
vraiment moins niaiseux asseoir puis
continuez votre boulot moi je vais faire
de mon côté ça plaisir d'entendre des
nouvelles pistes